listen I talk a lot about Christian
nationalism and the emerging threat the
under talked about and the
under-appreciated threat of white
Christian nationalism in this country it
has been a decades-long priority and
objective to be met by these Christian
nationalists to intertwine themselves
into government in an effort to take
over the government to force their
crypto fascist views on the rest of us
are you Jewish that should concern you
are you a nun you you don't have faith
in whatever religion religious tradition
it should concern you even if you're a
Christian it should concern you
because the flavor of Christianity the
doctrinal
point of view will likely not be the one
you share
and it will be imposed upon you